[Music]
let me tell you about this experiment
bart
we're gonna move on okay so
my life was crazy really intro
video like would you ever make out with
your mom
no you actually said that before i said
action
okay so i was like you guys don't know
what he said
because i told you my life is crazy and
he's like oh yeah
did you drink gasoline you ain't that
crazy
you're acting crazy you don't know what
crazy is girl
yep so this story here it has nothing to
do with
with gasoline drinking or making out
with your mom
so this one's about a team of
researchers from shenzhen university
and they found and they found via
experimentation that young males given a
dose of testosterone are more generous
when they are watched by
others what define how young and what
does it mean to be watched by others
okay so this experiment involved rubbing
good questions
rubbing a testosterone gel on the upper
arms and shoulders of 140 male
volunteers between the ages can you soak
testosterone this way topically yeah
really it works like that
it's a steroid still it's still starting
yeah testosterone i think i got too many
i don't want to take any more yeah he's
wearing overalls right now
okay yeah so uh the age because you
asked the age
18 between 18 and 25. okay yeah
so then they ended up doing this this
experiment where half of them had been
treated with the gel containing
testosterone the other one with the
placebo
and so then they waited for three hours
for the testosterone to make its way
into their bodies
and then they were asked to donate money
to a well-known charity
and so some of the volunteers were asked
to donate in a private setting while
others were donated to
to uh were asked to donate in front of
others
and that's when they found that the
those men who had received the gel with
the testosterone and who were asked to
donate while
others watched tended to donate the most
money
the test makes you like flex in multiple
ways i think so muscles
and your money yeah i think it's a power
it's like establishing dominance like i
could take care of people
i feel like that's what the test is
doing so if you want to make money
get a lot of buff guys around you but
people have to be watching those
people we're gonna test this topical
testosterone
let's see how much you donate don't do
that also maybe he has like some sort of
like do they all have the same financial
upbringing
like through what's the control factor
it's like i'm not i don't have
testosterone i also have no money so i'm
going to donate you know like what
how did that be we're gonna put on
testosterone now we're gonna see if
we're gonna donate money they probably
could have gave them all a thousand
bucks you know like
like each everyone gets dollars oh yeah
like like an allowance
like how much you want to give like well
[ __ ] i'll keep 20 bucks and then
yeah yeah fair enough this is a funny
variable
it is funny it is funny these
researchers they had also they had
looked into the fact that testosterone
in the body
is linked to status seeking behavior
by men so then they wanted to see like
how how far does this go so then they
realize
you're trying to go up the pecking order
the more testosterone you have picking
down
yeah duck order
oh i want more testosterone i want it
wait you should say you didn't want it
too many i think it's the pecking duck
that turned out
[Laughter]
[Music]
the more testosterone like naturally
people have it's actually the more
calmer you
are really is that true you sound really
calm right now let me tell you that
that's why because
it's kind of like if you are anxious and
nervous
you're not alpha then you're just
chilling because you just see like
like if you see like daddy gorilla right
and then people around them are like
fighting or whatever you just like
and then they stop but then like the
more
not so dominant guys will like be
extreme and big and like
be mr tough guy he has to overcompensate
and he's like super aggressive and [ __ ]
and then daddy gorilla comes by
and he just whacks him on his head and
then he doesn't waste that much energy
and he's just chilling what about the
chill guys who just don't give a [ __ ]
about anything
the surfer gorillas are for gorillas
what's up bro got high testosterone no i
just like to surf
by the way here's 20 bucks
[Laughter]
oh no one's watching no one's watching
let me get it back
only if someone's watching yeah i know
they're very specific about that
because of the status seeking behavior
that's like peacock and you have to like
make sure there's an audience and then
like oh is your alpha
oh peacock [ __ ] is that to say that
women have peace
is that to say that women don't have
those tendencies then like
women don't want to give they didn't
mention women in the study
they were just i feel like that's a
human behavior i feel like even women
have there's like a pecking order and
like you
you're they're status seeking that's
true because just earlier today we were
talking about the way we all tip
and i was saying like when i'm being
watched by the cashier and they flip the
screen around
and like they're asking if i want a tip
the fact that they're standing there
watching me
and there's others or i'm like okay yes
let's let's tip like i do feel like end
up being more generous because i am
being watched so i am interested to see
how they study women
you got a lot of testosterone you got so
much testosterone
that's what it is apparently maybe one
is like competitive tipping
because it's like i'll take care of you
and one is like social
uh shame tipping like everyone's
watching
25 good enough
[Laughter]
it's not a it's not like a uh what do
you call it like
like the same motive so just the result
is tipping but you don't know why
like like if people are competing i
think women and men both compete
if they're competitive by nature i don't
know if testosterone does that
but people that do have dystrosis they
seem more like always trying to like
um win or like be
be some yeah like you said with less
disaster more more testosterone you're
always trying to
win is it is it more primal is the idea
of
like yeah the alphas or people with
higher testosterone
or animals i guess um being very
uh dominant and care like nurturing like
they can take care of the pack
you know what i mean they're like the
strongest in the group in a way and uh
in a human currency that's like money
natural currency so it's like
i can take care of more
things you know what i'm saying so the
role of an old school king
was he made the decisions but he was
also the biggest and strongest dude that
would lead them into war
so it was like a charismatic uh
strong but also fair character so that's
what they strive to be not all of them
are like that obviously you have like
murderous dudes right
power hungry yeah what ends up happening
is like
they'll go in and then they'll rape and
pillage elsewhere but then they bring
you know more women more more more lives
more kids whatever more treasure
and then they bring it back and then
they spread it among the group
and then so the king is quote unquote
generous but at the end of the day like
he gets
to choose and make the decisions and
he's at the top
yeah but it's kind of like this weird
robin hood but not really yeah
i think in human yeah it's kind of like
that but if you think about
primates uh it's usually just a power
thing
but if you think about lions right like
the alpha
male lion is just chilling he's a baby
like monitor that's true because of the
lioness
ends up going and hunting he's a baby
factory he's just
[ __ ] nutting in the girls and just
chilling and he's like
trying to sleep and then the babies come
and bite him in the face and he's like
[ __ ] dude but he's he but he's
susceptible to
another male alpha to come in and then
when they come in they
have to fight for that dominant role
right so there's that's the only real
threat yeah there's a there's a life or
death element for
how that testosterone gets tested but
maybe for like the civilized
human being right we don't have to like
measure
our wits or anything like that in that
same space by like
now you've got this topical cream see
who's the last one's standing it's not
like that it's like
it's like here's this top screen so you
already have that like last man standing
and they're like here's some money who's
gonna donate
me right
but maybe it's like competition
and testosterone maybe there's a
correlation because
if you think about it right like in
every
alpha situation you get everything like
life is you you have to bear the
responsibility of like
losing that position or constantly
people competing with you
but if you think about it like if you're
super famous right what do you get you
get a lot of like treasures you get a
lot of
like people wanting you you get you know
popularity you get girls or whatever and
say for girls like if you're a top dog
in
in in that area it's like you get
rewarded for that
so maybe that drive is beneficial
for that i don't know person so they
keep doing it
or i don't know competition just i don't
know i think it's a part of being human
though
yeah i mean that's what propels humanity
forward yeah
yeah i really wonder what these
volunteers were donating
before the testosterone and then like if
they're comparing it there where it's
like oh yeah they are being more
generous
or what if like they end up being more
generous because then they're like oh
[ __ ] maybe i didn't tip enough
in the first study or whatever it is
because there's so many factors to
consider
it's such a weird study too like why
specifically
the hormone of testosterone and giving
that's what i'm saying
it was because it had been previously
linked to the status seeking behavior
oh so it was always status quo why the
rubbed in version
you know just like give me your ass what
if it was just
a a perverted lab tech that designed all
this
because he's like how am i gonna rub
some cream on some hot dudes
yeah and then oh yeah it's a study no no
come on bro
yeah yeah give some money they probably
should have done like other studies too
like the second you finish the donating
section it's like you go into the next
room it's like a wardrobe
it's like what outfit you're going to
put on you know what i mean
there's like sweat slides scrubs there's
[ __ ] royalty
like garb you know what i mean military
outfit anything business suit or just
[ __ ] silk like hugh hefner [ __ ] like
what are you gonna wear
they should have done a if it was about
status it should have been
like multiple things like what role
would you take or whatever right
because what if the charity was to some
[ __ ] they didn't believe in
and more people donated because they
believed in like this charity or
whatever there's just so many different
i mean
the fact that they said well known
charity too like that
the fact that it's well known might make
you want to donate more to it because
you're like oh this is popular like it
must be doing good with
the red cross testicular cancer
foundation from steroids
[Laughter]
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you